dear kitten it's been a while since
we've had some real talk you've grown
ugly just kidding but you're old enough
to know that well things have changed
like that thing when I was a kitten it
was no threat they used it to warm their
ears but it had a plan first it was
small things she just started staring at
it but then she couldn't stop touching
it I tried kneading it once and almost
broke a nail
I mean I walked in on her dancing in
front of it I think she's trying to win
its affection when it's some sort of
Warship and there's tiny people inside
and tiny cats too I've seen them what if
all of us are inside one of those and we
don't know it and we're being watched
right now I know I'm being paranoid I
mean if we were inside one could I do
this
[Music]
I still got it but one thing is clear
kitten we have to stop it
if she gets pulled in get in her face
whatever it takes
this is how we will win her back
dear kitten
you may be too young to remember the
horrors of vacuum I vanquished its
demonic howl by repeatedly choking it
with Susie until I saw it thrown outside
in shame I speak to you now about a new
threat this one is stealthy quiet always
moving always seeking it's creepy I take
solace in the fact that it is utterly
stupid look at it there's the sofa right
in front of you ah okay you hit it see
what I mean but keep an eye on it kitten
and if things go sour we can always push
it down the stairs like I did with never
mind
dear kitten even our private time is
changing there's something new Under the
beach somehow it communicates with her
through the box when we go that's right
the humans have become even more
obsessed with our poop than the dog why
is she smiling I'm trying to figure out
how to put a bell on her toilet seat
just for a spite
dear kitten long ago I discovered those
things that she puts on her face make
everything bigger when you look through
them I lost many an hour looking at my
own tail it felt like a freaking tiger
anyway the more recent updates to these
things are baffling looks like a robot
fanny pack trying to lick their head but
here's the kicker you can't see through
them feels like a very obvious design
flaw I mean she almost stepped on you
and fell over the coffee table but they
keep on using them
but I think it's some sort of a scam
most likely perpetrated by the poodle
next door I investigated one this
morning and can confirm they are useless
but whatever you do don't look them in
the eye
whoa what is reality really kitten just
a stream of sensorial data from an
unknowable Universe anyway
not all new things are bad like this
frisky salmon pate I don't even know
what Pate is but it just keeps getting
better
hopefully all these changes leave this
part of our Lives alone as perfect as it
is
Showtime kitten you know what to do
foreign